Bình bán ngày ra bong chóc ta tôn, chia m có thể quen khóc,
bình lòng lũi chào tuyên cả ngày dây nắng,
vui quẻ chết in anh đẹp thật đó,
nhưng ra thì đang gạo thét không lương,
nhẹ thì hương đò, hương lưỡa là cảm giác giác bong chóc sau vài ngày,
nhất là vùng vài tay cô.
Lúc này, tất cả những gì bật cơn,
chính là một vũi nhau nhà đà bì là gần nứt,
chỉ mới tạm phần chăm,
chất rào mong nhẹ, mắt lýu,
thôi thế đầu thấm ngày thế đó sẽ dù vạc chưa trải kirt định.
Sản phẩm chứng nước em nhà đam tươi,
gửi sê đuyên, phí tâm in e có thể dùng cho mặt và tỏa tân.
Chất rào trong dút như thạch,
toàn lên không bếng,
thùng nặng ra,
su hợp để dạy,
nhẹ chơi ra,
sau mong ngày nắng gắt.
Một hụi nhỏ em theo vô xú lịch,
là đồ để kêu ra khỏi phố dấp sau nắng.
Giang nhà đà bì là gần nứt chỉ mới tạm phần chăm,
đã có hàng chục nguyên lượt bán cùng,
cần mở phí pát tích thật tựa,
cái khán chỉ dựa chứa sản,